today we will dive into the vast and
varied world of Linux a Digital
Playground where unique versions known
as dros offered a tailored Computing
experience picture DSL a compact
Powerhouse at just 50 mb bringing old
computers back to life Marvel at tiny
core Linux incredible 10 MB size proving
that great things come in small packages
transition smoothly from Windows with
the intuitive zorin Os or embrace the
future with Chrome OS a portal to
cloud-based living for creatives music X
gnu plus Linux is a symphony of
multimedia tools each dis dra is a
unique pathway offering customization
power and Community Support we have a
flavor of lenux to match your taste and
before commencing just a quick info for
you if you are an aspiring cyber
security professional looking for online
training and certifications from
prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts to
enhance your credibility then search no
more simply learn postgraduate program
in cyber security from MIT University in
collaboration with EC Council should be
a right choice through our courses you
will gain knowledge and work ready
expertise in skills like Advanced
hacking Concepts Network packet analysis
ethical hacking network security and
over a dozen others the course is
designed to accommodate a diverse range
of Learners and requires just a
bachelor's degree with a 50% average and
you require no programming experience
and one plus year of work experience is
preferred if you're passionate about
making your career in this field then
make sure to check out the link in the
pin comment and description box below
now we are about to take a deep dive
into the world of Open Source operating
systems where diversity is key and
customization is Limitless each drro we
will discuss offers its own unique blend
of features usability and community so
let's get started and we'll start with
the first one that is uban 2 so uban 2
is a Debian based Linux operating system
that is designed for desktops servers
and increasingly for cloud and iot
devices it's known for its user
friendliness robustness and strong
Community Support uban 2 offers a secure
intuitive and feature experience with a
focus on accessibility and
internationalization it provides regular
releases and a predictable update
schedule and is often chosen for its
balance between cutting and technology
and stability so this was about the
number one dis now moving to the next
that is redhead Enterprise Linux and
before moving to redhead Enterprise
Linux we will have a screenshot of the
operating system here and you could see
how the UI of entu looks like now moving
to the next that is redhead Enterprise
lenux so rhel it's a commercial Linux
distribution designed for Enterprise
environments it's known for its
stability security and support rhl
provides long-term support certified
ecosystems and subscription based access
to updates and support services it's
widely used in hosting cloud computing
and as a reliable platform for critical
applications so moving to
the uiux of the red hat Enterprise
Linux so this is the screenshot for that
and now we will move to the next distro
that is deian so Dean is a free and open
source operating system known for its
stability reliability and V package
repositories it's governed by a
community of developers and users and
prioritize at ends to free software
guidelines dein is a versatile
supporting a wide range of hardware and
suitable for desktops servers and Amed
systems now moving to the next Linux
drro that is sus Linux Enterprise so
Seuss is a commercial distribution
focusing on Enterprise needs offering a
robust scalable and secure platform it
provides comprehensive support updates
and a management system designed for
complex deployments sus is known for its
y configuration tool making system
management more accessible now we see
the uiux for this Linux drro so this is
the present Linux drro uiux now moving
to the next that is Linux Mint so Linux
Mint is a one two based distribution
known for its ease of use and out of the
box experience it provides full
multimedia support a variety of desktop
environments and focus on user
friendliness Linux Mint aims to be a
modern elegant and comfortable OS which
is is both powerful and easy to use now
moving to the next drro that is
slackware so slackware is one of the
oldest distributions known for its
Simplicity and minimalism it follows a
philosophy of keeping it simple and as
uni like as possible slack Fair offers
no formal package dependency resolution
appealing to users who prefer manual
system configuration and understanding
the inner workings of their OS now we'll
see the uiux so this is the current uiux
of slackware Linux d
now moving to the next that is gento so
gento is a source based distribution
meaning the user compiles the source
code locally according to their
preference known for its flexibility and
performance optimizations gento provides
a unique system called Portage which
makes it easy to manage packages
dependencies and system updates you see
the current uux for the gento Linux Dr
so this is the current UI if you will
install it and see the homepage this
will be the same so now moving to the
next disto that is AR lenux so AR Linux
is a rolling release system focused on
Simplicity modernity pragmatism user
centrality and versatility it's known
for its minimalistic approach where
users only install what they need AR
provides a vast amount of upto-date
software and is backed by strong
Community documentation now moving to
the next Linux dist that is Fedora so
Fedora is a a Cutting Edge community
supported distribution backed by redhead
it's known for its commitment to open
source software and its role as a
testing ground for features that make it
to rhl Fedora emphasizes Innovation
features the latest software and offers
various pins tailor to specific use
cases and now moving to the next Linux
dto that is open source so op offers a
stable and feature platform for both
desktops and servers it's known for its
userfriendly configuration tool yes and
it's two flavors leap stability focused
and tumble weed rolling release open S
provides an excellent platform for
developers system administrators and
desktop
users so you can see the uiux for the
open S Linux testro on the screen now
moving to the next one that is Kuban 2
kubantu is an official flavor of kuantu
using the KD plasma desktop instead of
genome it's known for a userfriendly
experience and a beautiful graphical
interface KD plasma offers customization
and a wide range of applications and
more windows like field kuantu aims to
be a versatile and elegant OS suitable
for both newcomers and experienced
users now we'll see the uiux for the
same Linux Dr and it's on the
screen now mve to the next that is lentu
lentu is a lightweight version of ubu
using the lxqt desktop environment it's
designed for older computers or systems
with limited resources despite its
minimalistic approach lantu is fully
functional and user friendly offering a
simple and fast Computing experience
with low Hardware requirements and this
is the UI for the Linux testro lentu now
moving to the next that is
exu so xubuntu is an ubu variant using
the xfc desktop environment it strikes a
balance between functionality and
resource efficiency xfc provides a
stable light and configurable desktop
environment making xubuntu suitable for
older computers while still offering a
modern look and feel it's a great choice
for those who prefer a minimalist yet
fully functional desktop and moving on
we'll see the U for the Linux desktop
xubuntu and the next on the list is ubu
AD 2 was an official derivative of om2
designed for educational institutions it
aimed to provide a free open source
platform that included Educational Tools
for students and teachers while no
longer actively developed it offered a
range of applications tailored for
classrooms making it easy to deploy in
educational settings now we can see the
uux for the Linux drro ad 2 and and this
is for the educational institutions now
moving to the next that is easy Pez so
easy pz was a Linux distribution based
on entu for notebooks it a came to be
lightweight with a focus on ease of use
and functionality for mobile Computing
it featured a custom user interface and
preall applications optimized for
netbooks emphasizing web based
applications and services and now you
can see the UI for the same now moving
to the next Linux D that is zenal zenal
is a server OS based on ubu designed to
manage office servers and Network
Services it's an easy to use Linux
alternative for Windows Server offering
features like a domain and directory
server mail server and Gateway zentel
aims to simplify Network management with
a userfriendly interface and modular
design and now on the screen you can see
the UI for the Linux T
cental and now moving to the next that
is genus sense so genus sense is a
Debian based Linux distribution that
focuses on free software it's endorsed
by the free software Foundation genu
sense removes non-free firmware and
software from Debian to comply with
strict free software guidelines offering
a completely open- Source operating
system for users who prioritize Freedom
now moving to the uux for the Linux
restore genus sense and the next on the
list is pingos so pingos is an ubu based
distribution designed to be user
friendly and full of outof the boox
functionality it includes many
pre-install applications and tweaks
focusing on user experience and ease of
use it's stored for New Linux users and
those who want a system that just works
now we can see the present U of the home
screen of the piny OS Linux drro now
moving to the next on the list that is
Bodi Linux so Bodhi Linux is an ubu
based distribution using the Moka
desktop it's known for its minimalistic
approach and high customizability bod is
designed for users who want to tailor
their system to the preferences it's
lightweight resource efficient and
suitable for older hardware and now on
the screen you can see the UI for both
the Linux now moving to the zorin OS and
the last OS on our list so zorin OS is
designed to be easy for newcomers
transitioning from Windows it features a
Windows like GUI and the ability to run
many windows programs via wine it's
versatile with several additions
tailored to different users including an
educational
version now we'll see see the UI for the
zorinos so this is the current uiux of
the homepage of zorinos and there you
have it folks we hope you enjoyed this
insightful tutorial and if you like this
session then like share and subscribe if
you have any questions then you can drop
them in the comment section below thanks
for watching and stay tuned for more
from Simply learn staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upscaling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here